hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear yes even though it's
halloween week i'm doing these as well
like in addition to all the extra ones
that i'm doing so i hope you guys
appreciate all of these movie reviews
that i'm doing but yeah so this movie
right here
i kind of feel like this movie sort of
occupies
the same space as insidious and some of
the other kind of like james wan movies
but i'm gonna go out on a limb here i
don't know how much of a hot take this
is but honestly i think this movie i
liked insidious don't get me wrong
but i actually think this movie was
better um and i definitely think it was
scarier and i think a lot of that is
down to well it's down to a lot of
things actually i really really like the
concept of it i really like the acting
in it the fact that it's kind of like
taken very seriously it's sort of like
you know more of like a family like an
older kind of family dynamic there's a
lot of kind of emotional resonance in it
as well
and uh i gotta say i really really like
the addition of the old films in it i
think that really gave it something
extra uh and of course i am talking
about the movie sinister from
2012. now the director of this was scott
derrickson who i think also did the
exorcism of emily rose among other
things which is actually a pretty decent
flick i liked that he also co-wrote it
and the other co-writer on it was a dude
named c robert cargill now apparently
the idea for sinister came from a
nightmare that he had
after seeing the ring in 2002
which no judgment because i'm gonna say
i saw the ring in 2002 in the theater
and they gave me nightmares too and most
horror movies don't but there was
something like super creepy about that
one
so see robert hargill has said you know
i had a nightmare after seeing the ring
in which i went up into the attic of my
house and found a box full of old films
and one of the films had like a family
hanging on it so the opening shot of
this film which is a really great
intriguing opening shot is just this
grotty old film of a whole family
and they're all they all have hoods over
their heads and they're standing like by
this tree and it's daytime or whatever
somebody's obviously filming them from
far away
and they're all standing there and then
all of a sudden this branch which has
been partially cut through like falls
and kind of pulls everybody up and
they're just kind of like very slowly
struggling as they you know suffocate to
death so it's like a really really
creepy opening scene and it really kind
of sucks you in immediately i will say
too that i mean that being the best
aspect of it gonna say the second best
aspect of it i think
is uh the casting of ethan hawk now what
i heard i mean i've always kind of i've
always liked ethan hawk as an actor um
he's one of those guys that
you don't really necessarily think of
like out of the gate it's like he's not
super well known i mean he's well known
obviously but he's not you know one of
those go-to big a-list kind of actors
but he's always like really solid and
he's kind of one of those guys that when
you put him in your movie it like
classes up the joint and he definitely
does that with this because i really
really like his acting performance in
this i will say too that uh vincent
d'onofrio is in this as well although
his role he always classes to join up
too because i love him but
his role pretty much in this is just
kind of like an extended cameo i think
they just shot all his scenes in one day
but you know that's not to denigrate or
anything like that but i just really
liked that they were able to get such
great acting talent into this film and i
think it it's one of the things that
like really elevates it maybe above
some of the other kind of like more
generic sort of horror movies i do kind
of feel like the
i don't know like the the marketing for
this like the poster
uh maybe the trailer i don't actually
remember the trailer i remember seeing a
couple of other reviews that complained
that the trailer gave pretty much the
whole movie away but i can't really uh
speak to that because i don't really
remember if i ever even saw the trailer
which you know if it does give does give
the whole movie away that kind of sucks
but horror is better when you don't
necessarily know what you're getting in
for
uh but i think the marketing for this
they were trying to
you know market it along the same lines
as like i said like insidious or like
some of the james wan movies which like
i said i like those but they do have a
sort of generic
uh quality to them that i can't quite
put my finger on even though they're
good movies they're always just kind of
like to me they've always been kind of
forgettable but the first time that i
saw sinister i'm not saying like it
didn't make my sh make me like [ __ ] my
pants or anything like that but i was
like man that was like a that was like a
cut above you know what i mean it's like
for being marketed
like it was one of those kind of
james juan type movies i'm like it does
have aspects of that like it does have a
few jump scares that probably need to be
in there and stuff like that but you
know it does adhere to some of the same
tropes as those but there's just some
quality about it or some series of
qualities about it that it's hard for me
to like articulate or put my finger on
but it really does like elevate it i
don't know if it's like the way it's
shot like the editing there's just all
of these sort of factors that came
together and made this like a really
satisfying creepy
entertaining and sort and i really liked
the premise behind it too so i really
this this one i remembered a lot more
than uh some of the other ones like
insidious or
even uh the conjuring like the first
conjuring which like i said i feel like
a lot of people talk about the conjuring
as being like you know the best one from
this
of this ilk i guess but i would argue
too maybe that i think sinister is maybe
better than the conjuring as well i mean
i certainly remembered it a lot more and
i don't know it's it's kind of like
the thing about sinister is that
the idea behind it you know it's not
super believable
uh you know that it would work out like
this and it's a little bit convoluted
but i think that the acting performances
and the way it's shot and the way it's
like taken so seriously it's a very
adult horror movie and not in the sense
of like porn or anything but it's just
like a very adult like it takes itself
very seriously but not to an extent
where it's just stupid you know what i
mean it's taking the material seriously
so i think that helps you know when the
stuff gets like super really
supernatural like toward the end you buy
it because it seems like a natural
progression it doesn't seem like oh come
on now like that's ridiculous i mean
your mileage may vary maybe some people
when they saw where it was going we're
just like yeah no i'm not i'm not going
on that journey but i was totally hooked
and i was just kind of like all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna roll with this and i
think like i said it's a great idea and
it's not one that you see
done a lot it's kind of like a variation
of something that's been done before but
a little bit of a fresh take on it which
i thought was kind of cool
so what we have ethan hawk
is playing this guy who's named ellison
oswalt obviously named after harlan
ellison and patton
oswalt uh which you know nobody made a
secret of that and he is a true crime
writer
now
ten years ago uh he wrote a very very
popular true crime novel or it was not a
novel it's like a true crime book uh
called i think it was called kentucky
blood
and it got on the new york times
bestseller list he was on interviews
with tv and everything like that and so
he was kind of like oh his you know his
fortunes made he's a star now and all
this other stuff however
his books after that didn't do as well
and at this point he's still making a
living at it but he's kind of getting
broke
and so he's really looking to not only
recapture his lost glory like how famous
he was for you know five minutes in time
back ten years ago but he's also trying
to like write that one book
that's going to
make him his fortune and make every and
provide for his family he has a wife and
two kids and um you know and will solve
all their problems essentially
so his plan uh which he goes through
without telling all the entire details
to his wife and kids
is that he's moving from their house
where they did live uh to this house in
pennsylvania where an entire family has
been murdered well four of them are
murdered like the mom and dad two of the
kids but one of the daughters named
stephanie is still missing and no one
knows where she is presumed dead but
they don't really know where she is
so he decides that his next project
is that he's going to move into the
house where this crime occurred where
the whole family was hanged uh from a
tree in the backyard the house comes up
on the market and he gets the bright
idea that we're going to move into that
exact very house and i'm going to
investigate this crime
and we'll see what we can come to one of
the things that they kind of talk about
a lot in the course of the film is that
in some of his prior books he's actually
come up with some stuff that the police
missed and he's kind of like [ __ ] on
the cops a little bit
so when he moves to this town where this
still unsolved crime is you know on the
books it happened like a year or two
prior uh the cops are not super happy to
see him not only because a lot of them
have read his stuff and are kind of like
yeah you don't seem to like cops all
that much you think we're idiots who
don't know our ass from a hole in the
ground
but uh there was one prior book that he
wrote that apparently like some evidence
that he came up with like ended up they
don't really go into specifics of this
but ended up getting someone off that it
turned out was actually guilty so the
cops are not uh all that jazz about
being there now his wife and kids
they know that he's moved here he's
moved his family here uh for the sake of
a new book that he's working on what
they don't know is that this is the
actual house where the mass murder
occurred and he's very um he's really
evasive about this because at one point
i guess he's done this kind of thing
before but he's never moved into the
actual house he's always moved into like
a house that was like on the same street
or something so he could like research
it easier kind of get the vibe or the
lay of the land or whatever because at
one point his wife straight up asked him
this isn't one of those times where you
moved us into a house like a couple
doors down and he's like no absolutely
not which technically
is true
but
it's not too north down this is the
actual house she doesn't figure that out
until later but
it actually kind of gets older but but
he's kind of keeping it from her
because he's just so convinced that this
book is just going to be the this is
going to make his fortune and his fame
and everything's going to be fine from
there on out
so they move into this house and pretty
much immediately uh he hears something
up in the attic or he goes up in the
attic
and there's nothing up there
except for this one
box
and inside of this box he also finds a
scorpion which at first it doesn't
really seem like that means anything but
it does actually end up tying into the
mythology later on
so he finds this box and inside this box
are a bunch of super eight films and a
projector
now
he's very curious about this who could
have left this here you know was it the
last people i mean obviously the last
people that lived here are dead but it's
like he didn't he couldn't figure out
like who left him here
so he figures what the hell i'm gonna
watch these
so
the one uh little reel that's called
what is it called family hanging out
2011 and i was like oh boy it's not
gonna be good uh is the movie that we
saw from the very very beginning it's
just this uh super eight footage of
of at first it's kind of like a family
doing normal family [ __ ] but it's
somebody like from the bushes like
filming them like as though someone had
been stalking them and then at the very
end of the film uh is the thing with
them hanging
and uh someone filming it now
obviously he's like okay well this is
evidence of the crime that was committed
who was filming this is this the killer
um he thinks about calling the cops but
then he's like
well maybe not because maybe i can
research this myself
and i can uh figure out some [ __ ] that
the cops didn't figure out because he's
already had a confrontation with the
sheriff of the town who as i said is not
really really happy about him being
there thinks it's a very very bad taste
that he moved into that house and also
he's like you know you think cops are
idiots and that we don't figure and and
honestly the cop says from the beginning
he's like look that little girl that's
still missing you know i'm sure she's
dead uh this is probably something that
we should just like leave alone uh and
it turns out he was right about that but
of course ellison is uh not gonna have
it so obviously there's a whole bunch of
other super 8 films in there and because
the first one's called you know the
family hanging out and they ended up
actually being hanged and dead it's a
snuff film so the other titles of the
other reels starts to become ever more
uh ominous like one of them is called
family barbecue
one of them's called pool party
and uh you know so like i think one of
them is called lawn care so
you can imagine
what is on some of these movies but of
course
since he thinks this book is just gonna
you know be the end-all be-all
he decides that he's gonna like watch
all these movies which like i said are
snuff movies and these movies
are i think like the best part about
sinister because
they actually shot them they wanted it
as realistic as possible so they
actually shot them on actual super 8
uh stock and with an actual super 8
camera like from back in the day when it
would have been done and they did
everything like in camera there's not
that's the cool thing about this is
there's not really i mean this movie
only cost like three million dollars to
make so there's not like a lot of cgi
like i said there are some kind of
cheesy jump scares which you know i'm
not a fan of
but
i'll give this movie a pass because so
much of it is just like so well done and
it doesn't really concentrate and it
doesn't you know it doesn't lean too
much into you know quiet quiet quiet
blam you know what i mean it's not you
know it has a couple things like that
but it's not overdone like some of the
other kind of more james won ones are
which like i said just kind of gets on
my nerves
but yeah so he watches all these films
and uh basically you know the one that's
pool party is all of these people like
tied to these lawn chairs and they get
like dragged into the pool and drowned
and during this particular film he
actually he's watching it and he sees
like a little what looks like kind of
like a weird
face and it looks like the person whose
face this is even though the face is
kind of [ __ ] up it looks like a mask
or something
um it looks like this person is like
standing under the water like in the
pool while these people are being
dragged into the pool and drowned
so he's like well okay that's really odd
and then when he goes back and watches
all the other films uh the creepiest of
which is lawn care because that's kind
of like it's
somebody like it's at night and somebody
starts up a lawnmower and it's going
across the yard there's just like one
little light like in the center and then
all of a sudden there's like a person
there and like the lawnmower goes over
them now i will say this movie
there's not a lot of gore in it and i
kind of like that it's sort of like
restrained
even some of the worst [ __ ] from the
movie like whenever
like when uh the tied up woman gets run
over with the lawnmower
um you can kind of see it but you only
see it in the reflection of uh ethan
hawk's glasses so like i really like i
thought that was kind of like elegant
like the way they did that that you know
you see the you know you see them see
the movie of like people's throats
getting cut and stuff like that but you
only see it like in a reflection of his
eyes so it's almost kind of like you're
seeing everything through his horrified
gaze so i thought that was like a really
effective uh thing that they did
now obviously because all of these films
were left there and they're all
the same thing he's like okay well all
of these crimes are obviously connected
and they all happened in different
cities and they happened like a really
long time apart like in time so uh
nobody thought to link them together
because you know it didn't have the same
mo or anything like that it's like you
know there'd be one where there's a
whole entire family died because they
were all drugged and tied up in their
car and then the killer like set their
car on fire but he's like the more he
researches
he's like in every single case like the
whole family was wiped out except for
one person like one of the kids and that
kid was never found so that was kind of
like um you know the only thing that
linked all of these crimes together and
the crimes the oldest one goes back to
1966 and at this point it's 2012. so
he actually um despite like his uh you
know the cops not really being fans of
his there actually is one younger deputy
who i don't think he's ever given a name
he just calls him deputy so-and-so
just because of a conversation that they
have but the deputy so-and-so is like a
fan of his so he agrees he's like well i
can't tell the sheriff that i'm helping
you because he'd get mad but he's like i
really want to help you with your book
because i want to be in the
acknowledgments and he wants to be
deputies so so like for his help on the
book so he actually does agree to look
into some [ __ ] for him so the two of
them start to put together
all of the uh links of these now another
thing that he notices too other than
this creepy figure seemingly being in
the background of all the films which
significantly means that this is not
necessarily the killer because then
who's filming the stuff um you know so
there's that whole thing too that's like
another layer so as they start to kind
of look into it they're also start to be
what look like occult trappings because
not only is one
kid missing from each scene uh which is
never found they also have this weird
like uh you know this weird face that
seems to turn up in all of them um and
then there are also like this weird
symbol that looks like an occult it's
not like a pentagram or anything like
that but it looks like an occult sort of
symbol
so at this point ellison is led to kind
of like this professor of anthropology
or you know occult studies or whatever
he's played by vincent d'onofrio he's
there to provide some exposition about
what this occult thing means like he's
been brought in by the cops before like
on occult type crimes so what he finds
out he's like this is actually like
pretty obscure you don't really see much
of this but apparently this symbol is
indicative of this not exactly a demon
but he's like a pagan deity of some kind
called bagool and he's this guy he was
like a child eater was able to manifest
through images and uh this goes back
like way to before the middle ages and
stuff so every time if you like drew a
picture of him or something like that it
would like manifest him and he could
sort of come through images and he would
wipe out a family and then he would take
one child from the family and kind of
keep it so he could like feed off its
soul
so that's essentially what the mythology
of this is i don't think bagol is like a
real demon or a real entity or anything
like that it was just one that was
invented for the movie but i think it's
like actually a really good
idea and i also really liked the idea of
it being able to come through images and
there being images of it that you know
the more images of it there are it's
like the more powerful it is so at some
points during the film like i said as it
starts going more from like an
investigation into a serial killer which
is kind of how it starts out and it
starts going like in more and more
supernatural directions in the sense
that you know bagool who the kids in the
um you know they they call them like mr
boogie there's all these little drawings
and that's what they call them uh so
he's like the boogeyman is that he's
able to kind of come out through because
there's a few scenes where
he'll be he has like a uh you know like
a close-up of one of the films like with
bagool there it's like his face and it's
a still but then like it moves and he's
also able to come in and out of the film
so like i said he's sort of like a like
i said not necessarily like a demon but
sort of like demonic in the sense that
he can manifest himself in the real
world like through
images of him which is why
he's always appearing on the camera and
then i guess like prior to the families
being killed or prior to
him deciding which kid that he's gonna
take he always kind of like sort of like
starts possessing them or taking them
over and getting them to draw pictures
of him which is something that happens
too with ellison's family because he has
kind of an older son and a younger
daughter the older son i guess prior to
this has had problems with night terrors
and uh they had gone away but when they
move into this house even though he
hasn't told his family that this is a
murder house uh he starts having them
like really really bad and also the
little girl seems to be drawing things
and also the older boy is drawing things
like
that he probably wouldn't have known
like details of the crime and stuff like
that so obviously like bagol is kind of
infiltrating their minds and like while
he's deciding
you know which one to you know which one
to go for to take over and then like
wipe the family out another thing they
uh find out too like ellison and the cop
is that
there's a pattern
not only is this you know the same thing
where it's a whole family that's wiped
out in a weird way
and then one kid is missing and never
found
but there's also a pattern where the
person like whoever moves into the house
like after the family died like they
move into the house where the last
family died and then when they moved to
a new house then they all get killed so
it's kind of like goes across i know
it's kind of complicated to like lay it
out so what ends up happening is that
ellison who has had all these problems
with his family because you know
understandably he's getting so obsessed
with this case in this you know this
house that he's drinking a lot and he's
you know because he's getting really
[ __ ] up and he's starting to see
things like sees apparitions and stuff
in his house and he doesn't really want
to tell his wife about it his wife finds
out that this is the actual murder house
so she gets like super pissed off and
she's basically like you look you don't
even care about us you don't care that
you know that this is affecting our
family in this horrible way you just
give a [ __ ] about your book and he
denies this but
it's pretty clear that that's all he
does care about so in some ways i like
he i think that ethan hawk struck like a
really good balance in this movie
because he could very well
have been a very very unlikable
character he certainly is a very selfish
character uh in the sense that even
though he sort of makes noises toward
you know i write true crime because you
know i want to find justice for the
victims you know these kids are missing
or you know i want to find murderers
that the cops couldn't find and maybe he
does believe that
but
you can tell that he's very willing that
really he just kind of wants to be
famous i mean he had like taped all of
his old uh tv interviews and stuff and
he rewatches them and things like that
trying to relive the glory days like
back when he was number one bestseller
on new york times and stuff so it's like
yeah he might be writing for the victims
but he's mostly just writing for himself
and the fact that he's willing to put
his family in that much danger even
after he suspects that something
supernatural is going on just kind of
like leans into but in that sense even
though he's unlikable in that sense he's
still like a really compelling and you
still feel sympathetic toward him even
though even in his selfishness he's
still a relatable realistic character
and i think like the interactions
between him and his wife like after she
finds out that this is the house where
the murders happened and he and her just
like confronting him with like all you
give a [ __ ] about is your book like you
know your your son is
his night terrors are returning he's not
getting any sleep and he's all [ __ ] up
and everybody's making fun of them at
school because they all know we moved
into this house and it's like everybody
hates us and um you know and him just
trying to like justify it and they're
just like screaming at each other it was
just like a really really powerful scene
i thought and like i said there's a lot
of emotional investment with the
characters in this one even though
he has like some terrible things about
him you still like feel for him you know
what i mean which i think is like a
really good and i think so i think that
he was like the perfect actor to be in
this movie because he really lends it a
real weight and a real his character is
real complicated but you still like want
to watch him and you still really don't
want anything bad to happen to him so at
one point like he figures out like once
he figures out what exactly is going on
with this whole supernatural [ __ ] and
once he actually believes it he actually
does do the smart thing
and he burns all the uh the films and
he's just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] this book
i'm not doing this um you know my family
is actually in danger we're getting the
[ __ ] out of here so i guess they still
owned the old house they hadn't sold it
yet so he just like wakes him up in the
middle of the night he burns the
projector and everything and he says to
his wife it's like the middle of night
he's like pack the kids up we're getting
the [ __ ] out of here it's just that
there's no book i just [ __ ] it
um so she's like of course over the moon
she's super happy about it however
what he didn't know prior to this was
what i just mentioned that when the
families get murdered it's not when
they're in the same house as the last
family that got murdered it's when they
move to another house that's when it
happens uh so by taking his family back
to his old house he's actually become
the next link in the chain
without him knowing it uh so when he
gets back to the old house he is
horrified to discover that the uh that
all the films and the projector and
everything like that are in this attic
and even though he burned them all uh
they're still there
and he's like oh [ __ ] i'm super [ __ ]
now and it's not too much of a spoiler
alert to go he is indeed [ __ ] uh and
that's kind of what happens like i said
i don't want to spoil exactly what
happens because i don't know how many
people have seen this or not i mean it
came out a while back because back in
2012 but i don't know i kind of feel
like because the ones in the bigger you
know i keep saying like the james one
conjuring or universe and the movies
that him and his you know kind of uh
crowd made i kind of feel like they get
all the
accolades and this one i don't know if
it's necessarily forgotten but i feel
like it's one that doesn't get as much
attention as maybe insidious or you know
the conjuring movies or something like
that and i think that's a shame because
honestly i think this one is better i
think this one's
at least more memorable and i think the
addition of the creepy like super eight
videos uh you know the the films i mean
that really lent something i mean
there's not a lot
more much more creepy than like fine and
i find this really creepy like going up
to like your attic and finding these
[ __ ] creepy ass nut films in there
that were like old with no sound and
[ __ ] i mean that would scare the [ __ ]
out of me so
you know what i mean that's the kind of
[ __ ] that i like like finding something
in your house that shouldn't be there
and is like really not kosher um so i so
i think for me that's like a really
really creepy thing more than and yes it
has a supernatural element yes you do
have to suspend your disbelief because
it is this kind you know convoluted
mythology
but i mean props to them for trying to
do something like a little bit different
than oh it's just a ghost of a murdered
person or it's just a demon or whatever
i mean they actually did come up with a
whole mythology surrounding it and i
thought it was like really cool and
really original
so you know there's that too uh it
actually did i think it only cost three
million dollars to make for christ's
sake uh and ended up being quite
successful like it made a [ __ ] ton of
money so successful that they made a
sinister two now i can't speak to
sinister two i have not seen it
but
it seems like at least in the horror
community it seems like the overriding
uh you know opinion
is that it was really really shitty and
you know because it kind of seemed like
they were trying to make bagool
you know uh sort of like a new horror
franchise which you know there's nothing
wrong with that everything's got to be a
franchise nowadays i get it that's the
business model
but
i kind of feel like maybe they were
trying to force it a little bit too much
and i've one criticism i see of the
first movie too is that bagol the demon
looks too much
like who do they say look like like one
of those wrestlers like the undertaker
or something like that well the he got
the he used the makeup like the makeup
for it is sort of reminiscent of uh you
know kind of like the the corpse makeup
from you know like norwegian black metal
bands and stuff not exactly like that
but that's kind of what he was using for
inspiration
so i can see like it's not the scariest
uh you know monster ever
but like i said it's that's fine and
honestly i don't think it has to be all
that scary because i think that
the other things about this like the
relationships between the the family
characters the whole mystery of it and
particularly that that creepy [ __ ]
those creepy super eight films of the of
the families getting killed are just way
way creepy enough and and i like and the
fact that they're just like suggestive
rather than you know in the way they
shot the movie like i said where it's
just kind of like reflected or you just
kind of already turns away and stuff
like that so a lot of it's kind of left
your imagination um and i think that
makes it like way scarier so honestly i
think that was scary enough to carry the
whole movie um you know maybe they
showed too much of the monster like of
the ghoul like toward the end but like i
said it's a very very minor criticism i
mean overall this is a really really
solid really creepy
horror movie and like i said i would
argue that it is actually better than
some of the ones that get a lot more
praise than this one did so if you
haven't seen it i would definitely
recommend checking it out uh it's on
amazon prime i rented it on amazon prime
i think it might also be on hulu as well
i'm not entirely sure but
if you have seen it and uh you have
opinions about it let me know what they
are in the comments or if you haven't
seen it you know i'm kind of glad i
didn't completely spoil the ending but
you know you know
if you know you know you you'll have
seen it so uh yeah so that'll do it for
this flickers of fear and i will see you
guys on the next one bye